this gas cloud located 500 light years
away from our solar system
is about to become a planet
this process usually takes a few hundred
million years but
what if we made it happen much quicker
and instead of it happening so far away
what if it happened right next to earth
how would this new planet form
and what would it mean for life on our
planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a new planet formed in our solar
system
when a new planet forms it's a pretty
cataclysmic event
it happened with our solar system four
and a half billion years ago
the process created all the planets we
know today as well as our sun
but instead of all that happening
what if it was just one new planet in an
already existing solar system
if a planet formed in our solar system
it would take over 100 million years
but for the sake of this video we're
going to speed that up just a bit
first it could start with a gas cloud
entering our solar system
the sun's gravitational pull could cause
the gas cloud
to start spinning rapidly eventually
dust and rocks would form depending on
the gas cloud's location
we might be able to see this happening
just not with the naked eye
you'd need a decent telescope to be able
to see the planet form
most likely you'd just see a big ball of
space dust
although you won't be able to see this
planet very well
what you could see are thousands of
asteroids and other space debris
potentially hurtling towards earth
that's because as this
gas cloud continues to spin more and
more
dust and debris begins to form these
grain-sized
pieces of dust would start to heat up
then
they'd start smashing into each other
forming bigger and bigger rocks
this is known as accretion
this could continue to happen until some
rocks grew to a few kilometers in size
creating a planetesimal planetesimals
are like the building blocks of planets
eventually the planetesimal could become
so big that
it starts to attract other large objects
all throughout space
and with all these objects flying around
space there's
a good chance some of them could hit
earth
as the earth is getting hit by asteroids
our new planetesimal would continue to
get larger
and larger and will continue to attract
other planetesimals or other large
objects
this will continue until the
planetesimal gets so big
that it collapses in on itself and
becomes a planet
a sphere would form and any heavy
elements like
iron would sink to the center of the
sphere and
the silicates would float to the top if
the planet were big enough
and close enough to earth there's a good
chance that
this new planet could suck up and
destroy
earth completely we'd have no choice but
to wait
and watch the earth get completely
destroyed as it crashes into the new
planet
and then earth would be gone
millions of years later this new planet
would cool off
and life could form so sure we'd have a
shiny new planet but
it probably wasn't worth it if a new
planet were to develop in our solar
system
it could be the end of humanity
it's probably best we keep the solar
system just the way it is
what if instead of discovering the
creation of a new planet
we discovered an interstellar visitor
well that's a story for another
what if